So I love maths. And unfortunately, not everyone
loves maths as much as I do. And there are
many reasons for this. And in my previous
work, I have spent quite a lot of time showing
that maths can be fun, that maths can be delicious,
that maths can be creative, that maths doesn't
necessarily have right answers, that maths
uses your imagination.
But the thing that I'm addressing today is
slightly different. Because people often say,
well that's all very well, but what's useful
for? And I've often shied away from that question,
because I think we spend too much time going
on about how useful maths is, and especially
to young people. Since when did any young
person get interested in something because
we said it was useful? It's like introducing
a friend and saying, I'd like you to meet
my friend. They're really useful.
Or it's like trying to get people to eat broccoli
because it's good for you. Broccoli is delicious
it is also good for you. But then I thought
about it, and I thought, well, maths is useful.
And the way in which it's useful is because
it's illuminating. And the way in which it's
illuminating is because it helps us to think
more clearly. And wouldn't it be useful if
more people in the world could think clearly,
especially these days?
And so I realised that I felt a driving urge
to try and help with this current situation
we're in, where we find ourselves often surrounded
by fake news or claims or fake news-- maybe
it's fake fake news-- and divisive arguments.
People yelling at each other. People being
victims, exploiting, bigotry, prejudice, blame,
shouting, and tiny attention spans. And I've
always believed it's important to think about
all the things that I'm good at and do the
best possible thing I can with them to help
the world.
And I realised that in the current sociopolitical
climate, it was really important for me to
do something about that. And you might say,
what can a pure mathematician do about that?
And I thought, well, what I can do is I can
help us all gain better clarity about the
kind of arguments that are happening. I'm
not going to tell you what to think, but I'm
going to show you some ways that I find helpful
in navigating the rather confusing world that
we're in at the moment.
Because how can you make sense in a world
that doesn't? Well, I think that we can. And
so this is a message of optimism. I am an
optimist. That's why I'm in education. You
can't really be in education unless you're
an optimist. And we believe that the key to
everything is the young people and how they're
going to think better in the future, when
the rest of us have gone. Maybe that wasn't
so optimistic.
So the point of my talk is to show how pure
maths really does apply to our daily lives.
Usually, we think of pure maths as something
abstract and remote. But I am going to argue
that pure mathematics is, in fact, a framework
for agreeing on things. And mathematicians
have this curious ability to agree as a research
field. So we really make progress. Things
become theories.
In other subjects, people keep arguing and
arguing and arguing. Say in philosophy, there
are many theories, and you argue, and there's
never anything that's necessarily right. If
there's a philosopher in the room, they may
argue with me. But mathematicians have a very
clear framework for agreeing when something
has been properly justified. And this involves
setting up what you're talking about carefully
and then using logic carefully about it. And
this is sorely missing from many arguments
in life at the moment.
So, traditionally, pure maths is thought of
as remote and distant from the world, and
it's nothing to do with real life. But it
applies. Usually, we think of it as being
useful to applied maths, where applied maths
is then useful to maybe science, and science
is useful to, perhaps, engineering and medicine.
And engineering and medicine are definitely
useful. And they are useful to largely a numerical
part of the world.
And many people think that maths is all about
numbers, and maths is not all about numbers.
I do not do any numbers in my research as
a category theorist. And maths is about something
more than that. So while this view of the
chain of implications of applications of mathematics--
this view is important. There's more to it
than that.
So I'm going to argue that pure maths is about
how to think, and how to think affects the
entire human world. And that this is a direct
application. It doesn't have to go through
all those intermediate steps. And in fact,
I was at a very interesting event recently
about maths in the real world, and everyone
else was an applied mathematician except me.
I'm not an applied mathematician. I'm a pure
mathematician.
And one of the very interesting audience questions
to the whole panel at the end of the day was,
what maths do you use in your daily life?
How do you use your research in your daily
life? And I felt very, very validated, or
possibly vindicated, or maybe both. Because
the applied mathematicians all kind of said,
well, I don't really use my actual research
in my daily life. But what I do use is the
way of mathematical thinking and thinking
through things.
I thought, see? That's pure maths. I use it
in my daily life all the time. And I'm going
to show you how, including I'm going to talk
about analogies, the interconnectedness of
things, relationships of various kinds, pivots
between different contexts to help us understand
other people, and, finally, intelligence and
what I think intelligence is, or what it should
be.
So, first of all, analogies. I often like
to think of maths-- there are many ways of
thinking of maths. I often like to think of
it as a theory of analogies. Because what
we do is we look at things in common between
different situations. And then we say, oh,
if we forget some of the small details about
these different situations, they will become
the same.
So, for example, we might think about two
apples and two bananas. And we go, oh, well,
these two things have something in common.
If we forget that these are apples and that
these are bananas, then they just become two
things. And now they are both examples of
the same concept. And that's what abstraction
is. It's moving from the kind of real things
to something that they have in common.
And the thing that maths does is it makes
very precise what that thing is that they
have in common. We don't just say, oh, two
apples are analogous to two bananas. We say
exactly what it is that we're thinking about
that makes them analogous. And there are different
choices you can make for this. So, for example,
if instead we had said two fruits, that would
still be true, right? They're both still a
type of two fruits.
But in making that analogy instead, we have
made something much more restrictive. And
so we will leave out, say, two chairs, which
are now not part of this analogy. Whereas,
if we say two things, then we get to include
all of that in the analogy. So different levels.
There isn't one correct level for making the
analogy, but there are different levels that
are more or less illuminating for different
situations.
And the key in maths is that we say what level
it is we're using. The problem in life is
that we usually don't. And so we end up in
arguments about whether something is or isn't
analogous. And the answer usually is there
is a sense in which it is analogous, but is
that sense illuminating? And that's more what
maths is about. It's not this is right, this
is wrong. No, you're wrong. You're right.
No, I'm right. It's about what is the sense
in which something can be thought of in this
way, and how will that help us?
So here is an example, a more profound example,
from maths, where 1 plus 2 and 2 plus 3 are
both examples of a plus b. And this is an
abstraction which sometimes makes people shudder.
And sometimes people say to me, I was fine
with maths until the numbers became letters.
[SHUDDERS]
But the point of the letters is that we now
get to include more things. And we can study
something plus something generally all at
once. And then we can understand a lot of
different situations at the same time while
only having understood it once. And this is
really good if you're lazy like me, because
I don't want to do the same thing over and
over again. And pure maths comes out of not
wanting to do the same thing over and over
again. Once you've done it a couple of times,
you go, OK, I'm going to make a theory that
does that for me so that I don't have to do
it anymore.
Just like if I had been born before dishwashers
were invented, I feel like I might have invented
a dishwasher, because I really hate doing
the washing up. So we can take this further,
because if we now look at 1 times 2 and 2
times 3, we can go, oh, yeah, well, that's
a times b. That's what those things have in
common.
But we can now say, well, wait a minute. On
the one hand, we have a plus b. And on the
other hand, we have a times b. Both of those
are just things we can do to a and b. So that's
a further level of abstraction, which I might
write a blob b, where that blob is now an
abstraction from plus and times and could
represent any other kind of operation. It's
called a binary operation, because it takes
two things.
And sometimes that top level is really helpful,
because we can do things like talk about commutativity
in general. Commutativity is where a plus
b is the same as b plus a. And also, a times
b is the same as b times a. But that's two
things. If we just think about commutativity,
we only have to think about one thing. And
this is a very important way that pure maths
helps us understand more things.
Our brains are finite and a bit feeble. So
we have to be able to understand lots of things
at once in order to save our brain power.
And one way to save our brain power is just
to ignore stuff and simplify things by forgetting
important details, and many people do that.
But a better way to do it is to become more
intelligent. And as you become more intelligent,
you find ways of packaging things together
as one concept. And then you can understand
it as one concept, instead of having to carry
around 10.
Just like when you first learn to read, maybe
you spell out every letter one by one, and
it's very arduous. But then, eventually, you
start seeing whole words. And then it takes
much less processing power for your brain
than having to read every letter. And then,
if you learn to speed read, then you learn
to see whole phrases at once as units, and
then you can read really fast. And this is
how to think in that kind of way, packaging
things together.
So here's another example of some analogies
where different levels of analogy are possible.
Straight marriage and same-sex marriage are
sometimes thought of as being just the same,
because they're marriage. And then, other
people get very angry and say those are not
the same. So let's think about what level
of analogy we could use here.
If we think that marriage is just between
an unrelated man and woman, then indeed, straight
marriage is not analogous to gay marriage.
But if you think that, actually, it's between
any two unrelated adults, then they are analogous.
And instead of saying which one is right and
which one is wrong by definition, we should
think about the different levels that people
are using to make those connections.
Now, what happens next, often, is that the
people who oppose gay marriage get very upset
and say, well, the next thing we know, we'll
be allowing marriage between any two adults.
And because there are some young people in
the room, I've redacted what exactly is going
to go on here. Maybe you can work it out.
But then they say, well, if we allow it between
any two adults, well, maybe, then, the next
thing we know, we'll be allowing it between
any two humans. And then, maybe the next thing
we know, we'll be allowing it between any
two living creatures. And then, maybe the
next thing we know is we'll be allowing it
between any two creatures.
Now, logically speaking, any of those levels
has sound logic. That doesn't mean that they're
all equally morally valid. But what is certainly
true is that just because we are OK with this
level does not mean that we have automatically
included the whole level all the way up to
the top. So if somebody thinks that thinking
this implies thinking all the way to the top,
that isn't logical. We can then have arguments
about where is the correct place to stop.
But if we make precise what we're actually
using as the analogy, we can have a more sensible
argument, rather than just yelling at each
other.
So now I'm going to talk about the interconnectedness
of things, because everything is very interconnected.
We get told sometimes that growing up is about
becoming independent. But none of us is independent,
unless you're living in a cave as a hermit,
which you're not, because you're all here.
We all interact with other people, and nothing
happens in isolation. Everything happens together
with some other things that cause it to happen
in huge chains.
And my field of research, category theory,
is all about how thinking about how things
are connected can really help you understand
those things. Just like when you're studying
a person and thinking about writing their
biography, perhaps, it would be very odd to
just write about their character in isolation.
Whereas, if you write about it, you usually
write about their family relationships and
their friends and the people they work with.
And if you're getting to know someone, if
you just put them in a room by themselves,
it'd be quite difficult. But you can tell
a lot about someone by how they interact with
different people, how they interact with important
people, how they interact with serving staff
in a restaurant, how they interact with cashiers
in the supermarket or something. You can tell
a lot from how people interact.
And it's the same with any object. There's
always some web of interconnectedness that
adds insight to those thoughts. So here's
one of my favourite diagrams of interconnectedness.
I'm sure that we all know this, since we are
in London. This is a fantastic example of
something that is a logical diagram, because
this is not geographically accurate, right?
The stations are not in the correct places,
which means that sometimes hapless tourists
end up taking the tube when it would have
been way quicker to just walk four minutes
up the street. It's not clear from the map
how close things are. And once you're on the
train, it doesn't really matter exactly where
it's going. You just want to know where you
can get to. And so this basically just shows
connections between stations.
And that's what category theory does a lot.
Is says we're not worried about physical location.
What we're interested in is the conceptual
connection between things, how things are
linked according to what we're interested
in right now. Now, there may be situations
when having a geographical representation
of the tube is useful. Here is a geographical
tube map. I don't know if you've seen one
before, but it's pretty confusing. I find
it very interesting, thinking about how different
it is from the original one, and how fantastic
it was whoever designed-- I've forgotten who
designed the main one.
But once you start peering at this closely,
you kind of-- what I usually do is I find
the Circle line first. And then I kind of
orient myself using the Circle line. But this
isn't to say that one of them is better than
the other. It's just that they're better for
different purposes. And this is the point
of thinking mathematically. You can think
about certain aspects of a situation for some
purposes and other aspects for other purposes.
And what that can help us do is get a certain
flexibility to our thinking. Because one of
the great problems with the world at the moment
is rigid thinking. And I sometimes think that
strength, physical strength, isn't just about
strength but flexibility. Materials that have
some flexibility in them can be very much
stronger. And when cars crash, it's the give
of the car that crumples up that is actually
making it safe for us, because it's absorbing
the impact.
And I think the same is true of the way we
think, as well, that flexibility of thinking
and the ability to absorb new ideas and process
them is really important. So relationship
breakdown is something that I think about
in terms of interconnectedness. Because often,
people want to blame one person and say who
is at fault. And there are many situations
where it's really not that simple.
So there are some, in situations of domestic
abuse, where perhaps we can agree that is
really one person's fault. But aside from
that, it's often some kind of vicious circle.
So maybe Alex feels disrespected, and as a
result, Alex is unable to show love. And as
a result, Alex's partner, Sam, feels unloved.
And as a result, Sam is unable to show respect,
which is why Alex is feeling disrespected.
And what often happens is that one person
in a relationship cares more about feeling
loved, and the other person cares more about
feeling respected. And then, it goes around
in these cycles. And this vicious cycle is
something that we can then think more about
by thinking about what the arrows are representing.
So these arrows here are about actions, and
these arrows are more about feelings.
And once we've broken it down like that, we
can think about which things are easier to
change. Is it easier to change your actions
or your feelings? Now, personally, I think
it's easier to change my actions, because
the feelings are things that just happen.
And so then, for some people, maybe, they
think it's easier to change their feelings.
And there's no right answer to this. But when
you have a vicious cycle, if you understand
what's causing the cycle, then you can figure
out which arrow is the easiest one to break.
And maybe there's a theory that whoever has
more power in the situation should be the
one to take responsibility to break the cycle.
Now, this is a very important example, when
we think about police violence. Because this
vicious circle comes back if we think about
the fact that maybe police feel threatened
by black people, and that's why they show
more violence towards black people. But as
a result, black people feel threatened by
the police. And as a result, maybe black people
defend themselves aggressively against the
police, which means that the police feel threatened
by black people.
And this cycle goes round and round and round.
And every time there is some police violence
against somebody who isn't white-- and there
is a lot of that in America at the moment,
and there always has been. Every time, there
will be people yelling, saying, well, the
police are just trying to do their job. And
if the black people hadn't been aggressive,
nothing would have happened. And then the
other people yell that the police shouldn't
be aggressive.
But what we should really do is think about
how these things are all connected. And then,
I think we can think about who has more power
in this situation. And personally, I think
that it's the people who have more power who
should take the responsibility to change something
and find an arrow to break. But at least,
even if we disagree about that, at least if
we've understood this interaction, we can
have a more sensible conversation about which
arrows should be broken and who should break
them.
Another way of thinking about interconnectedness
is where I drawn myself diagrams of causation.
So when something happens, like the egregious
incident a couple of years ago when someone
was ejected from a United Flight because they
needed a seat for cabin crew-- and he was
ejected rather forcefully and sustained some
quite serious injuries on the way out.
And many people started yelling on the internet,
as they always do, oh, well it was his fault.
If he had just obeyed them, then he wouldn't
have been injured. And other people were saying,
well, you shouldn't just beat someone up because
they didn't want to get off a plane. And then
they just argue at each other. Well, kind
of both of those things are true, and there's
really a lot of things going on.
And I even read-- we're being filmed, so I
won't name this person. But I read a rather
curious editorial by somebody in a British
newspaper who declared that it's actually
our fault, all of us, because we're late for
flights. And the fact that we're late for
flights means that they overbook flights.
And because they overbook flights, they sometimes
have to kick people off flights, and that's
why that person got injured. So it's your
fault, all of you.
I mean, there's a tiny element of truth to
that, but it's a little bit tenuous. And so
I decided to draw a whole diagram of all the
things causing this, because it's never just
one thing, right? So the end result was that
someone was injured. And well, it's because
he refused to leave and also that security
used force. But the airline called security.
Someone had to call them in the first place.
Why did they do that? Well, and why did he
refuse to leave? He needed to get to work.
Why did the airline choose that person? There
are questions remaining about whether they
were racially profiling. Then, why did the
airline even decide to kick people off in
the first place? Well, they had to kick people
off because nobody volunteered. Why did nobody
volunteer? Well, maybe the airline offered
them too little money. They didn't offer them
very much money.
And maybe, for some reason, everyone really
wanted to get home. Well, that's kind of understandable.
Well, also, why did the airline even decide
to remove people in the first place? Because
the plane was too full. Why was the plane
too full? Also, why did they need to do that?
Because they needed some crew in Lewisville.
And why did they need some crew in Lewisville?
Maybe there was some issue with their scheduling.
Maybe it was their fault for scheduling badly.
And so why was the flight even too full? Well,
because they overbook flights. Why do they
overbook flights? Also, not enough people
didn't show up. And the flight was overbooked
because people often miss flights. So, finally,
we have that reason up at the top there.
But then we can think about which are the
most important contributing factors. And we
can think about which arrow shouldn't have
happened and who should have taken responsibility
for making sure that arrow did not happen.
So here is another example, which is why I
get fat. Now, I used to be a lot fatter, and
I lost 50 pounds, and I would quite like to
keep it off. And so I think about this. And
whenever there's anything about-- there have
been recent measures about trying to cut obesity,
trying to stop BOGOF deals on sugary things,
or trying to make people put the calories
on the restaurant menus.
And there's always somebody-- I always read
the comments online. People say, never read
the comments. I say always read the comments,
because if you don't read the comments, you'll
just stay in your own echo chamber. And you
should particularly read the comments until
you find something that makes you ill because
it's so awful. And I do that every day. I
honestly do, because I think it's so important
to stay aware of what people are thinking.
So, anyway, whenever there's something about
losing weight, someone will go, oh, well,
it's not rocket science. You just have to
eat less and exercise more. Well, even rocket
science is just applied maths. So why do I
put on weight? Well, I put on weight because
I take in more energy than I burn, which is
because I eat too much and because I exercise
too little. But it's also because of my metabolism,
and there are some things that change your
metabolism.
So, for example, eating too little and exercising
too much change my metabolism, which means
I put on weight. So it's actually because
I eat too much and also because I eat too
little. This is already getting a bit complicated,
right? So my metabolism is that way. Well,
it's partly because of genetics, and it's
partly because of sleep patterns, which can
change your metabolism. And why do I eat too
much? Well, I like food. But it's also because
of emotions, and it's also-- let's see what's
happening next.
I eat too much. It may be genetics and also
upbringing. Food is a lovely thing to have,
and we love eating food. And that's why I
like food. There's also social pressure to
eat too much. People think you're boring if
you don't just gobble everything up communally
with everybody. And then, there's also social
norms, but those cause emotions. So there's
also time pressure, so time when I'm stressed,
I get emotional. And I also sleep less, and
that doesn't help.
And then there's also life. Life causes emotions.
But then there's also the entire food industry,
which is, if you think about it, there's a
multi-billion dollar industry that is trying
to get us to eat too much. It's no wonder
that they're doing really well at it. So they
do advertising. The advertising makes us eat
more. And the growing obesity rates fuel the
diet industry, because they all want us to
go on diets that fail.
And this is all caused by money. They're trying
to make money out of us, and they've figured
out that they can. Moreover, when I do gain
weight, then I do all these things, which
doesn't help. So now we have all sorts of
cycles all over the place. So now tell me
that it's simple.
It is simple. If we become intelligent enough
to understand a diagram of interconnectedness
like this as one thing. And that's a much
better way of simplifying it than just saying,
oh, you just have to eat less. If you do just
eat less, then you have just deleted the entire
rest of the diagram. That is one way to make
this diagram into one thing. But a better
way is to become intelligent enough to comprehend
the whole diagram as one thing, and I think
that's a better way.
So I did, then, draw a diagram for the 2016
US election. A lot of people were yelling
about whose fault it was. Some people saying,
oh, it's all the people who voted third party.
Oh, it's Bernie, the Bernie or bust people.
Oh, it's Hillary's fault. Oh, it's someone's
fault.
It's a lot of things together. And sometimes
I feel like it's really not that profound
to say it's a lot of things together. And
yet, there are so many people trying to say
it's just one thing. So there is my diagram
for that election, which is one of the motivating
reasons that I wrote this book. Because I
was teaching in Chicago at the time, and it
was impossible not to talk about it and to
try and use mathematical thinking to help
understand the situation as much as possible.
So, relationships. We've talked about some
literal relationships between people and the
idea of relationships overall. I'm going to
show how thinking about relationships can
really illuminate some situations. And I'm
going to start by talking about factors of
30. Now, if you've read my first book or seen
me talk about my first book, this might be
a little bit familiar to you. But we're going
to take it further.
So the factors of 30, maybe you can remember
what they are. They are 1 and 2, 3, 5, 6,
10, 15, and 30. Very good. You passed. So
it's not very interesting. It's a bunch of
numbers in a straight line. And we can make
it more interesting, I think, by showing which
ones are related to each other as factors.
Because some of these numbers are factors
of each other. And we can draw something a
bit like a family tree showing how they are
related.
And just like a family tree, we don't need
to draw lines between two generations, because
we can deduce that, right? We don't draw a
line from grandparents to grandchildren. We
just via parents. So 30 is at the top, like
a kind of great-grandparent. And then 6, 10,
and 15 go into 30. 5 goes into 10 and 15.
2 goes into 6 and 10. 3 goes into 6 and 15.
And 1 goes into 2, 3, and 5. So now we see
it's a cube, which is a bit more interesting
than a bunch of numbers in a straight line.
We can think about why it's a cube. There
are lots of things you can do this. But if
we think about it, 1 is at the bottom because,
obviously, nothing goes into 1. And then,
2, 3, and 5 are there because the only thing
that goes into them is 1 and themselves. You
might remember that means that they're prime
numbers. So the prime numbers are at the bottom
level.
And then, the next level up, we've got things
that are products of two prime numbers. So
6 is 2 times 3, 10 is 2 times 5, and 15 is
3 times 5. And then, at the top, we have 30,
which is a product of three prime numbers--
2, 3, and 5. So we have a hierarchy now that
consists of how many prime factors each factor
has. And I can draw that one like this.
So at the bottom, we have the empty set. That's
the symbol for the empty set. And then we
have one-element sets, and then we have two-element
sets. And at the top, we have all three of
the prime factors-- 2, 3, and 5. And that's
how you make all the factors of a number.
You find all the possible combinations of
its prime factors.
Now, maybe it becomes clear from this diagram
that it doesn't really matter what those numbers
were-- two, three, and five. So they could
have been a, b, and c. So now we have the
same picture but with a, b, and c instead
and all the possible subsets of a, b, and
c structured using the hierarchy of ones with
two things, ones with one thing, and then
no things.
Now, we could try this again with 42 to see
if we understood it. So here are the factors
of 42. They're 1, 2, 3, 6, 7-- it's a bit
harder, this one-- 14, 21, and 42. And if
we draw the diagram again, now we can start
from the bottom, because we've understood
the prime factors should go at the bottom.
That's 2, 3, and 7. And then the products
of two prime factors, and then the products
of all three prime factors.
And what you can see, if we write it out using
the sets of prime factors, that it's the same
diagram. Once you've gone all the way up to
the abstraction of a, b, and c, it's the same
thing. It's just that we swapped out a five
for a seven in the middle diagram. And then,
to get back to the one on the far left, we
multiplied the numbers together that are in
each position.
Now, there's something very crucial I want
to draw your attention to in this new diagram,
which is that six is less than seven. Now,
this doesn't sound very profound, but if you
look at the diagram, six is higher up than
seven in this hierarchy. But six is smaller
than seven on a normal number line, where
we're just doing things by size.
And there is often a situation where there
are two different ways of placing things in
a hierarchy. And the crash between those two
different ways is what causes tension and
antagonism. Just like for example, if at work,
somebody older is more junior than somebody
younger who has been promoted over them, that
can cause antagonism.
Now, this has become very abstract. We've
turned the numbers into letters. And I'm going
to show you that there was a point to turning
the numbers into letters, which is it's now
very much more widely applicable, because
those letters could be anything. For example
they could be three types of privilege-- rich,
white, and male. And then, at the next level
down, we'll have everything with two types
of privilege. So we have rich and white, rich
male, and white male.
And then, at the next level, people with only
one type of privilege-- rich, white, or male.
And then, at the bottom, people with none
of those two types of privilege, three types
of privilege. So if I put back in the missing
types of privilege for emphasis, we have rich
white non-male people, so that we remember
that we are including non-binary people. We
have rich non-white male people. We have poor
white male.
Ah, yes, I'm using poor instead of non-rich,
because it doesn't fit sideways. We have rich
non-white non-male people. We have poor white
non-male people, and we have poor non-white
male people. And then, at the bottom, we have
poor, non-white, non-male people. So there
are many things that we can understand from
this diagram. We've gone from a cube of factors
of 30 to a diagram of interaction of different
types of privilege.
Now, the first important thing to notice is
that every arrow represents a loss of one
type of privilege. And it's important to notice
that this just means that if everything about
you stays the same but you just lose that
one type of privilege, then your position
in society will get worse. That's what the
theory of privilege says. It doesn't mean
that all white people are better off than
all non-white people.
Sometimes, people who are angry about this
theory get really upset and points at some
super rich black sportstar and say, see? They're
really rich. White privilege doesn't exist.
But that's not what white privilege is about.
It's about saying that if that super rich
sportstar were all of the same things but
also white, they would be in a better position
in society. For example, they would not have
to fear for their lives in America if they
get stopped by the police.
Now, there is something more that we can understand
from this diagram. If we look along a row,
there are no arrows going between things on
a single row, because they've all got different
types of privilege. But we can think about
how much privilege they really have in society.
So maybe we can think that rich white women
are actually doing much better than, say,
rich non-white men, who are probably actually
doing better than poor white men.
Because it turns out that money can mitigate
for many, many problems. And so, actually,
the rich white non-men are kind of there,
and the poor white man is sort of there. And
the same is true on the bottom level. But
actually, we can go even further than this.
Because if we think about the difference between
the two levels, if we think about poor white
men and we compare them with, say, rich black
women, we can maybe agree that it's definitely
possible for rich black women to be way better
off in society than poor white men.
And we can think about some extreme examples
like Michelle Obama or Oprah Winfrey. They're
definitely doing better than poor unemployed
white homeless men. And so, actually, the
diagram is like this. It's a cuboid. It's
not really a cube. And this has helped me
understand why some poor white men are so
angry in society at the moment, because they
are considered to have many types of privilege,
but they don't feel any manifestation of it
in their actual lives.
And I think it's much more productive to understand
the root of that anger rather than simply
get angry with them in return. And there's
a bit too much of just getting angry with
them in return.
So this kind of diagram, seeing these abstract
structures, can also help us switch contexts.
So we can pivot between different contexts
that have the same diagram in them, and we
can find analogous situations. So, for example,
in these cubes, 30 and 42 and rich white men
all occupied the analogous position.
And we can look at just one type of privilege
relationship and show that the relationship
that male people have over female people,
because they are dominant in society, is like
white people over black people, because white
people are dominant in society over black
people. And that's also like rich people over
poor people. And so the male people, the white
people, and the rich people occupy an analogous
situation in those situations.
Whereas, if you think about the relationship
that male people have to female people compared
with female people to male people, that is
no longer analogous, because the arrow is
pointing in the opposite direction. Now, of
course, it is analogous if you go one step
further and you just say, oh, well, it's people
and other people. But is that a useful level
of analogy to go? Well, we can have a discussion
about that.
But there is a sense in which male people
being prejudiced towards female people is
different from female people being prejudiced
against male people. And the sense in which
it is different is visible here, because there
is a power difference between them. Now, we
can then have an argument about how that power
difference manifests itself, but there is
a power difference. And in all of those situations,
when there is a power difference, it also
means that racism of white people against
black people has something different about
it from racism of black people against white
people.
So there's another thing here, which is that
something might not be at the top in one context
but be at the top in another context. So these
things aren't fixed. We're all in different
situations all the time. And in some situations,
we're more powerful than in other situations.
So when I'm standing in front of a class with
students and I'm going to grade their finals,
I have a lot of power over them. But when
I'm walking up the street and they're all
taller than me and can beat me up, then it's
less so. Not that my students would ever actually
beat me up, but that's how I feel when I'm
walking up the street, that more than half
of the population is stronger than me and
could beat me up.
So in this diagram here, rich white men occupy
the top position. But if we restrict our attention
to non-male people in the diagram, now it's
the rich white non-male people who are at
the top. And in fact, we could restrict our
whole context to women, and we could use rich,
white, and cis-gendered as three types of
privilege. Remember that cis-gendered means
that your gender identity doesn't match the
gender identity you were assigned at birth.
And we now see that rich white cis women occupy
the analogous position that rich white men
do in broader society. And this has helped
me understand why white women-- why there
is so much anger against white women in some
parts of the feminist movement at the moment.
Because white women may be prone to seeing
themselves as underprivileged relative to
men, because we all feel, everyday, sexism,
all the time. But on the other hand, they
don't remember how much privilege they have
over non-white women, and so people feel angry
about that.
Now, we're all less privileged than somebody
and more privileged than somebody else. And
so we should be able to perform these pivots
to understand what it's like to be in both
of those situations. And this goes both ways.
Because not only can we understand what it's
like to be in an underprivileged situation,
we should also understand what it's like to
be in a privileged situation. Not only because
of how other people view us, but also by what
it will feel like if somebody calls us out
and what a useful way would be to call someone
out without making them upset and defensive.
So here is a pivot that I have realised that
I'm able to do. As an Asian person growing
up in England, as I did, I have less privilege
than white people because of white privilege.
But also, I know that I am probably more privileged
than most non-white people, because Asians
occupy a slightly different position than,
say, black people. And so I can do this pivot
where I can understand racism from both points
of view. And I think this helps me to see
things from other points of view. And so it
helps me to empathise with people who have
different experiences from me.
So another pivot that I can do is about being
rich. Now, when I do the cube of privilege
and talk about being rich, almost everybody
puts themselves in the non-rich place, because
they all think that they're not rich. But
we're all richer than somebody, and we're
all less rich than somebody else.
So, yeah, I'm not so rich that I don't have
to work ever again, but also, I'm doing fine.
And there are people who are not doing fine.
They're struggling. They're unemployed. Maybe
they're working at minimum wage. And so I
can see aspects about richness from both points
of view, as well.
So here is the one about white women, where
white women often see themselves as underprivileged
compared with white men, and they forget that
they are overprivileged compared with non-white
women. And I think we're often prone to see
ourselves in the underprivileged situation.
And it would make better conversations if
we can always pivot to remember how we are
also overprivileged in other ways.
So, finally, I would like to talk about intelligence
and what I think intelligence is. Because
sometimes people have arguments where they
go, oh, you're just not being rational. But
what does rational mean? You're not being
logical. Well, if you study logic in maths
or philosophy, you discover that logic starts
with some assumptions, and then you deduce
things from those assumptions.
You have to start with some assumptions. Otherwise,
you can't get anywhere. So sometimes people
say if you are using assumptions, then that
means you're not being logical. That's not
true. But also, if you only use those assumptions,
then that's not exactly illogical. You just
haven't got very far with your logic. So some
people say that they don't believe in gay
marriage, because they think that marriage
is between a man and a woman, which sounds
logical, but all I've actually done is said
the same thing twice.
There may be other ways of defending that
that position, but that isn't a very good
one. But it's not illogical. So if I say,
I like this table, because I like this table,
that is logical. It's just not very helpful.
That's not very productive. And so being logical
is not the be all and end all of intelligence,
I think.
So I thought about it, and because I'm doing
all these diagrams of interconnectedness,
I tried to distill what I think intelligence
is about. And I think it's about being reasonable,
being not just logical but powerfully logical.
By which I mean that you're able to make very
long chains of deductions, both forwards and
backwards. So you don't just say, I like this
table, because I like this table. That's not
a long chain of deductions.
But if you can unpack a very, very long way
why something is happening-- which is what
mathematicians do all the time, because we're
trying to trace things back to their first
principles. That's, I think, powerful logic,
where you actually get somewhere.
So the last thing, I think, is that to be
intelligent, you should really be helpful.
Because if you just sit around making logical
deductions that don't help anybody, I don't
think that's very intelligent. We can argue
about that, but that's what I think. So then,
what is reasonable mean, and what do all these
things mean? I thought, well, what I think
reasonable means is that not only do you use
logic, but you have some kind of framework
for testing yourself.
And this is a really important aspect of the
scientific method and mathematical theories,
that it's not just that we have a theory and
we think it's true. There is a very clear
framework for when it is not true. And if
somebody wants to say it's not true, there
is a clear framework for how they do that.
And there's a clear framework for when we
should agree. So if they find a mistake in
our proof, then it doesn't actually mean the
end result isn't true, unless they can find
a counter-example. It might mean that our
argument isn't very solid.
With scientific theory, sometimes people say,
oh, scientific theories are just theories.
It's just some kind of statistical certainty
about things. But the point is that there
is also a framework for telling when you're
wrong. So there is a framework for deciding
when you're fairly sure about something, and
there is a framework for telling you're wrong.
And that makes it different from someone who
says, I just don't think the moon landings
happened. That's my theory. It's as good as
a scientific theory. Because they have no
framework for admitting when they could be
wrong. There is no amount of evidence that
would convince them they would think the entire
thing was fabricated. So if there is no possible
framework for someone admitting they're wrong,
then it's not really a framework. And I would
say they're not being reasonable in the sense
that one cannot reason with them.
So being powerfully logical, I think, is about
not just using logic, but having techniques
that you've developed for using logic that
help you get further, such as seeing things
in an interconnected way, pivoting between
situations. I also spend a lot of time in
the book talking about grey areas and how
we should deal with those, because they're
very difficult. Being able to see many different
causes of something. Being able to have ways
of unpacking things back and back and back.
And finally, how are you helpful? Well, I
think that to be helpful, you need to have
techniques for being helpful. But very importantly,
you need to be able to engage emotions. Because
being helpful, I'm talking about helping other
people. And if we don't engage our emotions,
then we can't be helpful to other people in
as much as we could if we do engage emotions.
And this works at many levels. It works at
the level of education, where if students
don't feel things when they're learning something,
then it is much less likely to go in. And
this is one of the problems with a lot of
science and maths education, that it's just
a bunch of cold facts, and you're just supposed
to follow these rules.
It's not the teacher's fault. If we think
about huge chain of causation, there are all
these regulations imposed on the teachers.
They have to meet these curriculum standards.
They have to prepare everyone for these tests,
and these other tests, and these other tests,
and these other tests. And then it just becomes
all about a bunch of tests instead of having
feelings about what you're doing and seeing
the amazing stuff and the horrible stuff and
the surprising stuff.
So emotions are a really important part of
this, I think. And too often, we pit emotions
against logic in a futile battle. Because
if you pit emotions against logic, I don't
know about you, but I think emotions always
win. Because emotions just are true, and you
feel them so strongly. If you're afraid of
something, then no amount of somebody logically
arguing with you is probably going to stop
being afraid of it. Well, not me, anyway.
Maybe someone more logical than me or less
emotional.
So I subscribe to Carlo Cipolla's theory of
stupidity. His theory stupidity is very interesting.
It comes in several steps. One of the things
he says is that every group of people has
the same proportion of stupid people, whether
that is children, adults, politicians-- maybe
more with politicians-- Nobel Prize winners,
professors, toilet cleaners, criminals. But
then he says, what does stupid mean?
And he also says, oh, and the proportion is
always the same, and it's always more than
you're expecting, even after you've taken
that into account. So this is how he defines
stupid. It's on a graph. And this axis is
how much you benefit yourself, and this access
is how much you benefit other people.
So if you benefit yourself but hurt other
people, you're a bandit. If you benefit other
people but you hurt yourself, he says that
you're unfortunate. So we could think of martyrs,
as well, but some people think martyrs are
benefiting-- well, anyway. So this is where
you help loads of other people but you hurt
yourself.
And I spent some time doing this, because
I believed that that was the noble thing to
do. And I think that quite a lot of women,
and men of a certain type, also do that. Because
we believe that being self-sacrificial is
noble and that our needs come last and that
we put everybody first. But that's not very
productive in the long run.
Now, if you hurt other people and yourself
at the same time, you are stupid. And so the
final quadrant is where you benefit other
people and you benefit yourself, and that
is what he calls intelligent. And I agree
with that, and I like it, because it has nothing
to do with grades, qualifications, standards,
prizes, money, status. It has nothing to do
with any of those things. It's about what's
really important in society, in my opinion.
And so, to finish, I would like to talk about
this, that what I've said is that logic can
actually help us empathise with other people.
We take the emotions out, but that can actually
help us to understand how other people feel
more instead of just getting upset with their
conclusion that we disagree with. And empathy
can also help us understand other people's
logic. Because once we understand how they're
thinking, we can understand the logic from
their point of view, rather than just trying
to understand it from our point of view, where
it makes no sense.
Because usually, when somebody is yelling
at somebody else that they're not being logical,
they usually are. They're just using different
logic. And if we can find out where the logic
is differing, then we can have a more sensible
conversation, rather than just saying, oh,
you're not being logical. And so instead of
a vicious circle, we could set up this a virtuous
circle, where our feelings and our actions
work together to help everyone around us as
much as we can.
And so I think that abstract mathematics really
can help us with this virtuous circle. And
that is what I wish for the world. My wish
for the world is that we would all try harder
to understand each other, rather than competing
all the time and trying to prove other people
wrong. I really think that abstract mathematical
thinking can help us achieve that, and I hope
that you'll join me in helping us all achieve
that. Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]